hello and welcome to machine learning
for biomedical data an introductory
course to applied high-throughput data
analysis this course is brought to you
by the Georgetown Medical Center in
collaboration with Pine biotech a
company specializing in big biomedical
data analysis the course materials were
prepared by our team from Pine biotech
and the Taliban dramatics Research
Center a University of Haifa Israel my
name is Ilya broadsky I am the CEO and
co-founder of Pine biotech together with
myself julia Panov dr. vladimir college
inca and stan Lubin have contributed to
the lectures and examples we will be
using I want to especially acknowledge
the work of dr. Lena Brodsky who is the
director of the Talbert bioinformatics
Research Center thanks to his dedication
vision and hard work we were able to
compile the necessary methods and
datasets to make this course possible
you can learn more about his work and
the TPN 4 platform by going to T - bio
info the second person critical to this
course is dr. Sona lassoo d'avin who had
the vision to start the systems medicine
program at the Georgetown University
Medical Center her program was started
in 2011 and is providing students with
the opportunity to learn about the
application of systems biology
approaches and tools to biomedical
problems so let's begin by defining the
purpose of this course what do you think
about when you hear machine learning
while many people will think of formulas
or maybe of code maybe flowcharts of
algorithms or even benchmarking stats
that compare machine learning methods
between themselves and while computer
science mathematics and algorithms are
definitely irrelevant to the study of
machine learning that will not be the
focus of our course in this course we
will only briefly touch on these
technical aspects of machine learning
and instead focus on the following
we will learn about key machine learning
methods we will learn and understand
their applications and especially to
biomedical challenges we will develop
critical thinking about how to select
and use these methods and in what
situations learn to read and understand
scientific literature especially the
kind that uses machine learning
terminology in the method section well
this will allow us to see through the
hype that we often hear in so many news
articles you can hear that machine
learning will revolutionize biomedicine
or artificial intelligence will
transform healthcare or some people say
that it will even take over the world
but that will not be the focus of our
course we will try to gain enough
experience to be able to speak to others
about machine learning with
understanding we will be able to explain
the methods and understand what others
say about them finally and most
importantly we will gain experience by
applying these methods to interesting
projects so what is machine learning is
it different or how is it different from
data mining statistics or computational
biology is it the same as artificial
intelligence does it have to do with
data types methods or their application
let's dive in and lay some foundation
for what machine learning is and how it
is used for high-throughput biomedical
data machine learning can be separated
into two main categories of methods
unsupervised machine learning that
focuses on detection of patterns and
data the main idea is to apply
techniques that are automated and rely
on various assumptions about data to
learn from it the second main category
is the supervised machine learning these
methods are relying
availability of training date data that
has already been labeled once a data set
of label data is accumulated it can be
used to train a model that will be able
to apply this knowledge so to say to
analyze new data for example by
predicting its class with unsupervised
machine learning methods we start with a
data set typically it's going to be a
table of elements like these shapes we
can use a clustering method for example
hierarchical clustering a method that
essentially seeks to identify groups
based on similarity or dissimilarity or
we can use a dimensionality reduction
method for example principal component
analysis or PCA and this method will use
data variance to project the elements
onto a hyperplane that we can visualize
and as a result will provide us with
insight into our data and the different
types or groups of elements that are
present in some cases we can use the
results to draw other conclusions about
the data within such a structure for
example in this case we can see that the
groups are based on shapes of elements
within the group supervised machine
learning takes in data that has to be
labeled typically this is done by people
in biomedical projects this could be
clinical data or some other phenotypic
data the label data is used to train a
model the methods vary as do the
principles used to build the model for
example linear discriminant analysis
will attempt to draw a separation line
between the Centers of classes in the
training data but whatever the method it
will essentially learn from the
differences between various classes that
are present in the training dataset
once the learning is established you
have a model or a template that can be
applied to new datasets new data can be
assigned with a class that is present in
the Train
dataset so if something doesn't fit the
model like this star model accuracy will
be reduced
how are these methods used for
biomedical data I mean you probably know
how machine learning can be used to
match audiences with interesting social
media posts or how it is used to predict
stock market financial data but how is
it applied for biomedical data for
clinical purposes especially in clinical
research disease mechanisms treatment
selection and development as well as
predictive models can be very helpful in
our course we will use machine learning
methods for patient stratification
disease classification and diagnostics
as well as predicting response or the
lack thereof to treatment and trying to
understand the mechanisms of disease
onset and progression importantly the
same methods could be applied to
challenges of interest to the
pharmaceutical industry so we will
address those as well during our
sessions I hope you are as excited as I
am to start this course in our next
lecture we will talk about the types of
data that we will use after all machine
learning has been around for quite some
time and arguably many of the methods
are statistical methods so what has
really changed why is it that only now
we are using machine learning in talking
about artificial intelligence and
biomedicine a little history and
examples will help us understand how the
challenges have changed and new
opportunities emerged from new data
technologies advanced computational
resources that are widely available and
improvements in machine learning methods
as well as their combinations